even at A hurricane's embarrassed by
vice president Harris once again she
fell on her face because she made it
about race it was a weekend of harsh
damaging wind but that's what you get
whenever Kamala is at the microphone
well speaking at the dnc's women
leadership Forum the VP managed to take
something that should have been unifying
a National Emergency called a hurricane
and of course made it about race so cam
who should be first in line for disaster
Aid it is our lowest income communities
and our communities of color
that are most impacted by these extreme
conditions we have to address this in a
way that is about giving resources based
on Equity understanding that we we fight
for equality but we also need to fight
for Equity understanding not everyone
starts out at the same place
sorry to all the Florida white guys
good luck with your flooded living room
I'm surprised you didn't add good thing
white people are better at swimming
she's a big egg
but hey at least common is great at
listing our accomplishments
in years two years as vice president and
many years uh um holding office in
California what is what are the major
changes that you have seen
a lot over the years
but there's still so much work to do it
we should applaud the work that we've
we've seen result in
progress
how beautiful
beautiful so what do you do about a Veep
who puts the her in disaster
Bill Maher says she's got to go
suggesting biting bumper from the damn
ticket in 2024.
once you have that real estate and you
wake up in the White House and your
office is the oval I just don't think
you'll give it up very hard to take the
nomination away from the president
uh assuming president and what I could
see is replacing the vice president
[Applause]
and it didn't seem to work out well his
audience applauded
so it's a great idea if you're Biden you
know remember when Abe Lincoln got rid
of Hannibal Hamlin in 1864. although
unlike Lincoln Joe came in the into the
office with brain damage
but Joe said he made history as the
first president to have a black woman as
VP and now he can also be the first to
fire one
of course like his son Joe's not above
using a woman and then asking her to
leave
foreign
[Laughter]
but maybe instead of pushing Carmel out
the door the answer is even simpler
maybe she just needs more bongos
have described rightly which is that it
is our lowest income communities in our
communities of color
that are most impacted by these extreme
conditions and and impacted by by issues
that are not of their own making so I
mean
absolutely
it always makes it better
professor
you notice that they're now pushing out
the word equality and replacing it with
equity which is basically a way to it's
basically top down equality instead of
boosting people up it's kind of scary
what did you make of this I should say
that I'm not feeling targeted again
about Canada because Kamala Harris grew
up in Montreal my high school played
against her High School where roughly
the same age I missed a penalty shot
when she was there I blame her for my
misspelled again
but but honestly let me mention this
probably I comment about diversity
inclusion Equity I've said this about
Trudeau but I'm now going to a serpent
for her if you take my career of almost
30 years as a professor add up all of
the students I've had rank the dumbest
student that I've ever had that person
would be about a hundred times smarter
than this lady
[Applause]
at regarding diversity inclusion Equity
I mean it's not just in these kinds of
contexts you see at the University
everything now is meted out based on
diversity inclusion Equity you get a
professorship based on immutable traits
you get scientific grants based on
immutable traits it's the most
fundamental violation of what made the
West great which is individual dignity
and so now we're losing it one inch at a
time yeah it's true science is supposed
to be independent of that stuff Joe but
instead it's not what say you funny guy
I I think when Biden said his vice
president he said she has to be a woman
and she has to be black he should have
said and a third thing
this would also be a third thing that
she needs because there's no way he's
going to be able to kick her to the curb
no and imagine how she feels when people
looking at her and saying you know what
we think this guy's got a better shot
than you and and he can't even get off a
stage without a crew of people coming to
to handle him yeah and move him around
it's um it's really the idea that he
would be reaching out to marginalized
communities the only marginalized
Community he reaches out to is the
deceased that's looking around for yeah
and even dead even dead people say we
see Joe Biden yes so he said
he's obviously in the pocket of big
Ouija board it's bad now what I don't
like is
his word Equity because Equity does not
mean need and we've got people who are
hit by a hurricane it's pretty easy to
figure out who needs help right now and
then to say no it's going to be this
group that's that's really
unconscionable it should say that what
do you think cat
I think this is the like the worst she's
ever looked because talking about this
is probably the easiest political layup
of all time right like nobody is
pro-hurricane so how did she still
manage to piss people off when she was
talking about it
it's it's not a contentious issue
she's such a bad politician they should
have been the one thing where she could
have done okay and no blew it she blew
it it was yeah I think the basketball
tournament is it was a layup young lady
I play sports I
actually I actually wrote that down oh
did you yeah that was what I chose
because I'm a sports gal myself yes yes
Emily uh the the sports gal has but this
is something that was a unifying event
and yet she was able to take something
that like every American puts aside
their team sport politics and works
together and she said black and white
women in minorities hit hardest yeah
he's like the worst kind of doll
possible where you pull the string and
there's three sentences she says and
they're all unconstitutional not just
unconscionable but literally
unconstitutional shadiest straight up
racist to your point yes the all
Americans care about all Americans we
care about Americans in distress and for
her to come out of left field at the
time when people have lost everything
and have lost their family members and
our vice president knee-jerks this
talking point that she thinks will win
her votes because she is that worst kind
of elite Democrat liberal which is you
will listen to what I say you will vote
a certain way you should think a certain
way because of your skin color and
therefore you should vote a certain way
okay she keeps ramming it down their
throats um I think there will be a
reckoning a hundred percent and the fact
that we've already started to lose the
late night talk show hosts the other
ones yeah um I think it's a big I think
it's a big indicator interesting yeah
she'll be invited back
[Laughter]
up next did the strategy to slow coven's
transmission hurt young people's
disposition hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else